altes glas treffen wo ist unglaublich
und zusätzlich kriegsheld alle
ich glaube ich überlege dubstep skript
ich glaube ich hinterlegt einfach so
einen dubstep ding wenn dieser krippe
kommt und wenn ich's vergesse dann tut
mir leid ich bin dumm hebt foul
ich bin doch ich bin dumm ein bis
anderthalb oder so gläubig und
zusätzlich alle
wir mussten
mit dabei ist heute luca com
wir sind auch in der gleichen stadt oder
doch nicht
ich bin ja ich hab ne ich hab eine taste
gedrückt ich bin in der riesigen map
drin
ja du musst wieder änderungen und das
glaube ich nein ich bin in einem
waypoint das ist ganz schön weit weg ich
bin weg meine lieben freunde ich bin
gerade sogar ich habe mit casper
dungeons geblutet und ich gericht vor
der sturm als zu lokal ich weiter wie
das kompakte modul aluta wenn ich mir
noch mal eins von hinten
bei den acht mir wurde gesagt ja die
natur ist so schlecht du stimmst
häufiger als als kontrast dann endlich
kann ich ja nie aber den und ich wollten
uns einen plan entwickeln wie wir
nämlich debitor der sv streit technik
und kracht und krieg wichtig dass wir
den einfachen ja also eigentlich also
endlich sicher branchen der stimme reden
dann regen sich alle auf
ja das war heute sucht geworden komplett
folge 20
rhedes wie so ein kleines kind läuft wo
schluss die burgenländischen vollkommen
ok damit okay also den verzehr einer
anderen stadt also es gibt ja statt
rotieren ich muss mal was produktives
man nämlich rumlaufe trainer noch nicht
völlig baff erdhütten für nicht lassen
stecken
es brennt es brennt es brennt auf dem
platz getötet das sogar ein anderes
vertreten
das hat mich grad
erinnert an den 1 das mittlerweile schon
ewig her alter
das ist mehr als ein jahr her junge ich
weiß nicht genau was drin wer von den
jetzigen zuschauern kind das denn
überhaupt noch erkennen ja alter das mit
mich auch mal interessieren nämlich mega
alt
ich habe mir vor ein paar tagen sogar
noch mal eine folge angeguckt weil ich
das in der auf falsche richtung
natürlich auch gut weil ich das bei mir
noch in der playlist gesehen habe und
alter wie niedlich das war micro villa
da würde ich so zunächst geschickt ich
sollte so busy kreml hole damit den weg
machen
dann wirst du voll aufgeregt weil wir
dann in die höhe gegangen sind ich
richtig gebaut
da war ich am brennen und form über
wasser und ich bin dafür die frist
abgelaufen oder die mittlerweile sogar
yoga wie dorf wird oder im bett ja ich
weiß noch als und als damals von
schluchten noch das ziemlich neues ja
oder ich weiß ja so erfahren aber schon
zwar die neue warte mal standen im haus
drin stall aus meinem haus hier sonne
ding immer hsv
ich hab grad fast gefunden alter ich
glaube ich habe stets haus gefunden
krokodil 90 ich hab keine stelle
gefunden erstickt hausboot gefunden
der richtig viele regionen wohnt er sich
so eine tür durchgegangen war ich da bin
teleportiert worden jetzt gehe ich
wieder zurück entstehen das hausboot ja
dazu ein hotspot bei mir
wobei stehen geblieben
wer damals waren halt so wie man sowas
relativ flecke ich meine diese die solo
auf neues und so eine unterschiedliche
schlucht ball direkt unser unter unserer
stadt werden seine eigene zweier stadt
so die eigentlich gar nicht
und dann hatten wir der glas darüber
gebaut ja aber erstmals die gefunden
haben wir wollten
und dann hatten wir irgendein gasthaus
an urlaub und der ist dann ein paar der
stadt ist eine schlucht ist sondern hast
du dann komischen eingang hin gebaut
oder darf ich daran sind fans darüber
gebaut wo ach ja war diese dieser alten
zeit
das war okay ich muss noch neun oder
blöcke lauf und wird gerade nach da
halte ich hoffe ich schaffe das
neulich hatte ich hatte wohl wind bot
aber diesen kaputt gegangen oder dass
diese erste soweit weg
ich war mit kev ein bisschen tanzen okay
das reicht auch schon mal gemacht ich
musste aber nie zurück laufen manchmal
gestorben das war ganz praktisch er
richtet sich so aus er denkt er stirbt
aber egal wie hoch ihr zuhause
ich bin aber ohne witz vor meinen toten
einmal erster tod brauner bär
er guckt mich an ich denke ich denn die
als online box nicht einmal dann wollte
ich ihm kuscheln eingestellt
denn einfach mal so wie bei schülervz
damals war mir dann sondern facebook ab
mitarbeiter dieser bär
der fand das nicht so recht hat er
mitgemacht die frage habe ich gesehen
hast doch einfach krass getötet er fand
es nicht so witzig was da hätte ein
verrückter jagen und weißt du mitten
während als er gestorben ist davor
dachte ich mir ja ich bringe zum ja also
spaß mäßig und ganz auf einer als er
gestorben ist fakt ich habe mir dann
getötet
es ist einfach ein regelverstoß und das
ist ja ablauf aber schon der
facebook-page gesehen lukas außer kraft
heraus aus eurodance und deinen kopf von
der durchgestrichene zum startzeichen
aktuelle logo das kann ja gesehen
mikroprojekt den heraus aus mir heraus
aus megaprojekt 30 minuten unterbrechen
recht gesehen ich bin übrigens zu hause
aber jetzt werden so plakate draufgabe
werde mich rauskriegt daneben eine
belohnung das ist so wanted for alter
unser mpc offizielle riesig groß
geworden wo wir haben ja alles
mittlerweile wird sogar eine top form
na ja das sollte aus der stadt raus
gegangen bist haben wir dann doch okay
du kannst was können wir was bauen
das konnte allerdings bei saalfeld user
ja wir wollen ja eigentlich auch so was
man hat ja gesehen dass ein bisschen
karlstadt rund es streit geräten
richtiger bis heute wie können wir tief
so ist der twitter youtube
aber wie gesagt das tief yve komme wo
die gruppe sei zu plötzlich kommen bei
mir ähnlich
jetzt gibt die stadt nicht sondern
sterbe ich darf ich da nicht so schnell
kommen
tötet mich getötet fast ihr seht schon
bei stadt roth da sind die auf dem darß
soll sich alles gehört nicht verhindern
er hat mich würde ja er ist zu mir
gekommen hat das auf mich geschossen da
war ich in der wand gestorben fast wäre
ich habe meine show coupe die meisten
los bei dem ich brauche ich muss
natürlich ausnutzen
ich brauche schmerzensgeld mehr
weißt du noch verschmerzen
was da drin
ein ganzes schmerzensgeld was erst ganz
praktisch auf jeden fall was da los ist
da drin
ich brauche ein schoko hier sind aber
nur grün und blau und ich kann wie kann
ich ein schoko für mich gewinnen dass er
mich mag samba mit mir ich musste mich
kurz darauf konzentrieren was ich am
besten kann noch kommen
wie kann ich ein grünes tor körper
machen
damit ist auch schon so dass das volk ja
aber ich die ganze politische folge
gebracht
das geht gar nicht wirklich wer kann
ixia das ist voller stärker zeit macht
man das so
das ist aber beträgt das selber auch
wenn ich ein bier oder ob ich das bei
mir nachher sehe regt es mich auch auf
ja ja ja wirklich
ich hab da sie haben das früher mal
einer 650 sechsten klasse also ewig
sprache haben wir das genannt gesprochen
das war so schlimm und es gab ein
elternabend deswegen ehrlich ja dann
weil wir auch in der klasse zugesprochen
haben ja relativ raschen während immer
in die eier geboxt und deswegen gab
seltener dabei verletzt hat sie jetzt
größer alle sind hier schon vergeben
alle chocobos ich kann dir keinen mehr
holen für mich aber dann habe ich jetzt
ein combo das klappt in unserer stadt
kann man nur einen schoko haben das weiß
ich nicht ich habe ob der allerdings
mich liebt weil tobi ist das ja ähnlich
den mir brock brocken stumps der die
nehmen sich einfach mal in schokobraun
ups ich so hell warum habt ihr euch das
genommen nur ausgeliehen krieg so bald
wieder drei wochen später sich das
geschiebe hinterlassen sie immer noch
nicht wieder oder was jedoch ich habe
jetzt wieder steht in meinem garten aber
das ist nicht mein schoko das ist ein
anderes meint hat er nicht so komisch
aber das liebt mich das denn oder nicht
das weiß ich nicht
meistens durch die werde ich kann jetzt
peter pan
sie sollte an die peter pan
ja ich muss diese stimme ist nicht
gucken nie wieder den er jetzt lieber
mbm bmf war hat das kart einer hand ich
kann dir was bringen
geht nicht ach wir wollten uns eher
treffen soll ich mal versuchen bei tommy
zustimmt es gibt es gibt ja bei sonne im
haus angeblich ein paradies benutzen
oder nicht wir machen einfach jetzt cool
noch hat eine verantwortung ich habe die
sachen geklaut und hatte nichts dagegen
also reden okay da steht ich bin jetzt
bei zombie unten
das ist so gebaut wie das zu gefällt hat
das kann auch hier geht's zu simon aber
ich habe extra zugebaute mit luca nicht
durch kann ich hab's nein da steht den
ablauf das tor wieder nicht das macht
mir nichts für das ganze nicht immer
macht ihr ein foto davon
naja ok solche als durchgehend schick
mir snapshot soll ich da durch den
anfangs denn die jetzt durch finden die
benutzer dann mach ich jetzt ins netz
stellt für dich den dadurch natürlich
gehen okay ich mache jetzt erstmal
snapshot snapshot für mich mitten in der
aufnahme denn er macht jetzt mich ans
netz nicht jetzt die durch die uno ich
bin bei simon ich bin euch ich will mir
statt rot grün statt rot wo was ich hab
mich hier raus ich bin ich bin ich ich
ich ich bin hier oben im großen turm der
wie ein penis aussieht am wasser ja ja
ja ich weiß du bist ja ich sehe ich bin
der stadt roth das zimmer also ging ich
keine ahnung was du gemacht hast rumpelt
hat mir was geschickt wo du bist an den
komischen berg darum drin
da treffen als glas treffen wo es gesagt
hat
barista granja direktwahl das hat mir ob
es geschickt oder ist weg
jetzt hat man die ganzen namen davon
gesehen ist das schlimm wenn man die
namen sieht von meinen nachnamen ja
deine handynummer alles nicht ich will
was du jetzt du hast blickt man mal man
den aber verschenken ich wollte erstmal
wir wollten dass marcel fit machen fürs
netz
den kriegt ihr wart bz wie mache ich
mein sonst mache ich das denn du musst
dein kamera changing ja ja kam kamera
change
ich weiß jetzt ansätze in den musst du
irgendwann pflanzen wo ich kann mich
drauf setzte mich bereit und ich gucke
noch eine facetime betrachtet mit dem
letztlich glaube es hat funktioniert
aber ich weiß noch nicht genau
ich habe dir ein kleines geschenk
zusammengestellt ich habe meinen
sekunden ding gemacht glaube ich 1 1
sekunden video dann hast du ein neues
video das gedrückt gehalten müssen
einmal drauf drücken und das schicke ich
dir jetzt aber okay wenn ja ich habe
fertig machen hingeschmissen
jetzt habe ich eine stadt für dich
gemacht habe mir nicht einfachen
hingeschmissen
wo von ich und danke das heißt dass
meiner kiste genommen mir dann geschenkt
danke mehr
ich habe hier noch was für dich und noch
mal dann hast du noch da bist du draußen
drauf ich boxe ich einmal du bist fast
tot vergibt man hier nicht bin dann tot
wenn am bocksberg dass ich alles
unordentlich gemacht alles war richtig
ordentlich ich wollte dich ran kam luca
manca kommen wir mit rüber in meiner
stadt ja von uns in einem college
playboy haben einen friedenspakt hier ja
wir beide am frieden okay okay
egal wer es ist wird ein ewig rechnet
auch weg ist wir müssen immer
zusammenhalten ist doch logisch
ja ja ich weiß gar nicht mehr was wohin
gehört findest du es nicht schön bei mir
ich kann deinen nächsten folge einfach
nicht besuchen
ich finde das schön ja wir nehmen das
auch toll auf beim ein snapshot connery
seine tasten bekommen ich bin da gar
nicht drin
mein handy lädt gerade und lebte
darunter du weißt ja ich bin durchgehend
online bis zu nicht erfasst anhusten
gestorben wenn ich was mit dem ding
runter gesprochen
passt auf dass ich auch schon fast
passiert aber nur fast
ich sterbe normalerweise nicht weiß ich
nie einfach und überall was schön ist
auf deinen denkt gebaut auf dein haus ja
ich sollte auch so zu reden
was kann ich mit dem star piesbach hast
du familie cloud nein ich habe das
selber zwei vorgefunden
er hat auch ganz viel davon das ist
nichts worüber man sich aufbringen
müsste da darf man auch nicht
umschreiben im tor unter verhältnis etwa
irgendetwas gar nichts bringt wurde wie
gesagt okay aber sieht so schön aus
ja ich freue mich auch mal wenn ich
sowas sehe und den lauf dahin mit ganz
viel gebrüllt dann komm steh dir
überholt mich weil er so eine besondere
rüstung hofft gesehen vorfall nicht
runter nein nicht das glas grüne
hierdurch jetzt ist mir einfach
runterschubsen
du bist auch frech ich hätte ich hoffe
ich das schaffe ich schon selber prima
hingekriegt fall schaden ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich irgendwas an
ich habe die goldene feder ich hab' ich
kann ich ja keinen fall schaden stimmt
wenn man eine goldene feder hat keinen
verstand nee ich kann nur eine geben
willst dann haben wir auch nur einen
goldenen feder in der hand und dann
stirbt man nicht mehr kriegt kein wald
schaden du musst ihn um inventar haben
wirklich reicht wird von meiner haben ja
gerne hat noch ein ja doch nicht gegeben
ich habe ja auch eigentlich so was
glaube ich oder ich weiß ich zeig mal
und da wir machen die eben eine zeigt
mal bitter ist dass er von schokologo
kommt nein das war dass wir schön alte
mann der millionen stück ja das habe ich
bewusst gewollt nehmen und einfach eine
feder nur mit das sind eine normale
feder
das sind so sachen die müsst ihr mir die
kommentare nur einfache sachen die aber
trotzdem sinnvoll die weiß ich nicht ja
vor sich da können komische creeper
rauskommen dass das dämmmaterial da
musst du einfach nur ganz viel von
abbauen und dann kommt das ist der
kasten richtig gute rüstung noch machen
die sache magnetisch anzieht das wird
mir schon abbauen wenn es bei euch nicht
in der nähe ist nämlich so dass abbauen
weil das war halt ein riesending hat ja
schon was man abgebaut ab so aber nicht
so wack reeber kommt müssen weg laufen
aber es sollte ihr risiko no risk no fun
des mammutprogramms um ein
aber da kamen hat gar nichts er hat eben
du musst halt manchmal kommt da nichts
draus und du brauchst du musst ich
glaube und du brauchst nichts anderes
wenn braucht man nichts teures anderes
aus als das ding selbst weißt du okay
und welche leistung kann ich darauf
machen
der meteor ist und ein meteorit hier und
ist sie gut ja also die skizze als ich
die fast voll hat sie fast war die auch
aber das ding fast voll
als hättet ihr als komplette rüstung und
aber diese rüstungs balken komplett voll
bist doch so eine bis zu anderthalb oder
so gläubig und zusätzlich
ich glaube ich glaube ich überlege
dubstep skript ich glaube ich hinterlegt
einfach so abbing wenn dieser krieg
kommt und wenn ich's vergesse dann tut
es mir leid ich bin dumm faul sein gutes
stichwort kontrast und das war's mit der
heutigen folge markt in der folge
besuchen wir mich und macht mir text und
noten instagram bild und ein instagram
will runter schaut auch bei könig vorbei
und checkt man die alten kader schon
voraus und so weiter und wir den bären
getötet hatten so weit kommt bei denen
wir in der ersten folge vom pferd
getötet wurde
ja nee lieber nicht lieber nicht